here is a once in a lifetime chess move
the bishop and night Checkmate may have
the highest difficulty on this list even
Hikaru struggled to execute it in a
recent tournament he might not do that
he might not be able to do it he's down
to 25. Kevin oh Bishop B3 and he needs
to get this way yeah
yeah
with a draw for he didn't do it probably
motivating every other top player to
brush up on the pattern in a different
recent event Danya neradinsky showcased
his Mastery of this theme
that's how you do it hey Caro you do not
have to execute the bishop and knight
checkmate as quickly as Danya did here
you can also practice it on chess.com in
games highly recommended